let's take a look at the pages structure
and see if something needs to be changed
in the instructors notes you'll find a
Dom built from the design check the link
I'll go ahead and open it here by going
and opening the file because I have it
saved my local machine and we can see
the design here it doesn't quite look
like our original mock-up let's see if
we can change it so it does I'll go
ahead and open up the developer tools
for that I'll press command option I on
my Mac there'll be links in the
instructors notes for instructions on
different operating systems now that
I've got my developer tools open let's
take a look first off let's go ahead and
modify the header I will open up the div
and we can see that the header at the
top of the screen is highlighted and
let's go ahead and make some
modifications around the whole thing we
need a row so I'll right-click on this
div and click at attribute I'll type in
class equals row by adding row here
we've changed the way this element on
the page looks inside of our row we need
some columns so I'll right click on the
first and click add attribute here I'll
type in class equals column medium six
indicating that we want the column right
here to take up half the page this is
supposed to be the logo that's on the
left side of the header I'll press ENTER
and we can see that now this div only
takes up half the screen let's do the
same for our name I will right click on
the div and click Add attribute and once
again we want it to take up half the
screen so we'll type class equals column
medium six press ENTER and now we can
see our two divs are to each taking up
half of the header now I'd like you to
go through the divs for the rest of the
page and add some classes do your best
to make this website look like the
mock-up but be warned you might have
some structural problems make sure
you've got all the right divs on the
page you might find you need to add some
divs to this page in order to structure
it properly for bootstrap what steps did
you take to meet bootstraps requirements
for the page structure did you add a
container div outside of your rows did
you add divs to organize your columns
in two rows or did you add columns
inside rows to organize your content
check all that apply